That's what I love
about money ‐‐
no emotions, no tears,
just reality.
Narrator:
It's been a remarkable 10 years.
I'm seeking
a $100,000 investment...
Narrator:
Over 1,000 entrepreneurs
have walked down these halls,
seeking their piece
of the American dream.
With close to $125 million
invested in the Tank so far...
Is this gonna
change the world?!
Narrator:
...and astounding successes...
We have a deal!
[ Laughter ]
Narrator:
...it ignited America's
entrepreneurial spirit.
‐Whoo!
Narrator:
And now the Sharks are back
for an epic 10th season...
I see more beverages than
anybody else in the country.
You may not have to go out
and raise money
if you partner
with someone like me.
Narrator: ...and exciting
titans of business return...
I want to know
a little bit more about you.
I think that watching
"Shark Tank" as a kid
helped me be standing
in front of you all today.
We've grown up
on this show.
And remember, there's
only one Mr. Wonderful.
And thank God for that.
Narrator:
...and brand‐new Sharks
jump into the Tank.
Former NBA superstar
and broadcaster Charles Barkley
is a prolific investor
and committed
to helping entrepreneurs.
You seem to be
on the right track,
and I'm willing
to take the chance.
Matt Higgins is vice chairman
of the Miami Dolphins
and is co‐founder
of RSE Ventures,
which invests
in innovative companies
across multiple sectors,
including sports,
lifestyle, and technology.
When we work together,
it's gonna be "Game over."
And Jamie Siminoff,
the founder of Ring,
sold his company to Amazon
for over $1 billion
and is the first
"Shark Tank" entrepreneur
to return as a Shark.
"Shark Tank" has inspired
a nation to chase their dreams.
[ Motorcycle engine revs ]
Man: This has been
a lot of my life,
and I just want to share that
with people.
There is a tenacity that I have,
and nothing's gonna stop me.
What you've done
is just inspiring.
Narrator:
And the dream continues now.
Kevin, they say
you're wrong.
I'm never wrong!
I'm always right!
I will make you
a millionaire.
Riding all the way
to the bank, baby! Yeah!
Whoo!
[ Laughs ]
‐Oh, my gosh!
‐We got a deal!
Welcome to "Shark Tank."
Look, I'm just an investor
trying to scratch out
a living here, okay?
♪♪
Narrator: First into the Tank
is a solution
to an annoying problem with
our furry best friends.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Tyson Walters.
And I'm Miles Walters,
and we're from Orange County,
California.
Our company
is Shed Defender,
and we're seeking $250,000
for 10% equity.
‐Hm.
For the millions
of dog owners out there,
this is an all‐too‐familiar
situation.
Greiner: Ew!
Dog hair gets everywhere!
It get all over your house,
it gets all over your car,
and it gets all over you.
Stop with the endless
lint rolling.
[ Corcoran laughs ]
Ugh!
Stop constantly having
to sweep and vacuum.
Let's face it, Sharks ‐‐
shed happens.
But now there's a way
to prevent dog hair disasters.
Introducing
the Shed Defender.
Ta‐da!
Come here, Harley!
Come here.
[ Claps ]
‐Aww!
‐Oh, my God.
‐Hey!
‐Oh, good dog.
‐How you doing?
‐Good girl.
Come here, baby.
This is the Shed Defender.
It's a onesie that contains
the dog hair within the suit.
It can be used in the car,
the house,
family and friends' houses,
or anywhere you don't want
to leave a trail of hair.
‐Harley!
‐It's like long johns.
It is.
The Shed Defender is made
from a lightweight,
eco‐friendly,
and breathable fabric
that allows your dog
to shed naturally.
Herjavec: No way!
And most importantly,
it's safe, comfortable,
and veterinarian‐approved.
The Shed Defender allows you
more quality time with your pet
and less time
cleaning up after it.
So stop wearing
your dog's hair
and let the Shed Defender
wear it for you.
So, Sharks, who's ready
to throw us a bone?
‐Oh, my God.
‐I got to see.
‐Come on up and see it.
‐Come up and see it.
It's crazy.
I'm gonna pass out
some samples.
Hey!
We figured you'd love her.
Ohh!
We have two of the dog models
for you guys
to kind of
play around with.
Where's the zipper?
So, that is how it works.
Thank you.
So, you can see the zipper
down there at the bottom.
And then, Mark,
we got you blue...
Perfect.
...so it'll
match your, uh ‐‐
Mavs colors.
Your Mavs.
Corcoran: How does your dog
feel about this?
She loves it.
So, you can actually do
a number 2 without a problem?
‐Oh, yeah.
‐It's wide open.
‐It doesn't get on it?
Yeah, no, it's wide open,
so male, females,
it doesn't matter.
Why don't you walk us
through the numbers?
We've been selling
for about 18 months.
We've done $1.2 million
in sales.
‐No!
‐What?
‐Good for you.
‐What?!
Yeah, we've sol‐‐
Are you serious?
25,000 units.
Yeah, in that 18 months,
we have sold 25,000 units.
Wait, wait.
Where did you sell that?
We sell on our site
and Amazon,
and we just started
wholesaling.
And how much does
each one sell for?
We have
nine different sizes.
The small one, the mini,
retails for $39.99,
and it goes up to
our giant size, $62.99.
And what does it
cost you to make?
Landing cost,
the mini is $6.23,
and it goes up to $13.20.
‐Great. Wow!
‐You're killing it.
We got about
an 80% profit margin.
You're making a boatload
of money.
We're starting to.
So, I started with just
the shedding aspect, right?
But after all
the customer feedback
after selling thousands
of these things,
another key benefit,
it reduces anxiety.
It keeps a dog calm.
Cuban: It's like
swaddling a child.
Yeah.
We have
a third benefit ‐‐
it can replace
the medical cone, as well.
The cone of shame.
Does the dog not get hot?
It's lightweight,
breathable fabric.
And when I developed
the product,
that was the main thing
I had in mind.
Also, it's for
situational use.
It's not for permanent use.
It's not for days at a time.
It's for hours at a time,
car rides.
Oh. So you don't
leave your dog in the...
‐Yeah, no. No, no.
‐Oh.
Do you have a patent pending,
did you say?
We do, but we have
foregone that.
You let it go?
Like, the time came ‐‐
you applied...
Yeah.
When I first did it,
the first utility patent was
done several years ago,
I didn't have the money.
I didn't have the funds.
O'Leary: So, you're not worried
if you build this business
and it gets traction,
maybe gets to $5 million,
basically, anybody can
knock you off, right?
That is the risk,
but ‐‐
Yeah, I'd rather have
the problem of having
$5 million in sales
with 82% margins.
Yeah.
Herjavec: So, hang on.
$1.2 million this year.
Tell me what the next
two years look like.
What we want to get to next year
is $2.5 million in 2019 ‐‐
But how are you
going to do it?
Give me a step‐by‐step...
Step‐by‐step process?
...so I appreciate how
you're really gonna get there.
I mean, number one
is wholesaling.
We would like to get into
the big box stores, so...
I hate to say this,
but with multiple SKUs, right,
across multiple colors, there's
an inordinate amount of risk.
On the other hand,
you get better at SEO
and particularly on Amazon,
and your margins are
80‐plus percent, you know?
You could make more money
selling half as many units
with 1/3 as much cash.
Guys, I think it's
a great business for you.
I think what you've
accomplished is amazing.
I'm not a pet industry guy,
so I don't know
that I'm gonna help put
any accelerant on it.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
Okay, thank you.
Thank you very much.
Thanks, Mark. Appreciate it.
The first biggest lie
every retailer tells you ‐‐
"You need a lot of SKUs.
We need more SKUs."
It has put more young
entrepreneurs out of business
than any other lie
in the industry.
True.
I would slow down.
You got something great here.
You've grabbed on
the end of it.
Why don't you keep doing
more of what's working
before you go off into
that never‐never land
called "retail," all right?
As a business,
I just can't relate to it.
I'm out.
Thanks, Barbara.
Appreciate it.
Okay. Thank you.
Guys, I like it.
I think it's absolutely nuts.
I didn't believe it.
‐It's a great idea.
‐But now I get it.
Listen, I'll throw
something out here.
I'll give you ‐‐
it's $250,000.
I'll do it for 33%.
Cuban: Ohh!
Okay, thank you
for the offer.
Hey, it's an offer.
We really appreciate
the offer, yeah.
And there's only one
Mr. Wonderful. Remember that.
‐Yeah.
‐Thank God for that.
True, true, true.
Okay, I really like it.
It reminds me very much
of Tipsy Elves, Sand Cloud ‐‐
unique, a little bit kitschy,
but with a real application.
We've got lots
of inventory issues,
and we're all online
in those businesses.
So, I'll give you the $250,000
for the same 33%.
I'm a much better Shark
in this deal than Kevin.
Kevin hates animals.
I want you to know
that I actually speak dog.
Okay.
And so I know exactly
what that dog is thinking.
Greiner: Speak a little dog
for us, Kevin.
So you're just matching
my offer.
So, you're matching his.
Yeah.
Okay.
So, I don't agree with
the thought
that you shouldn't be
in retail.
You have a really good,
strong online business.
I think you should also have
a TV‐shopping presence,
because
this is demonstrable.
You need to show
why is this great,
as opposed to crazy,
right?
You need
to blitz the market,
because if you let go
of the patent and all of that,
you just really have to be
first and strong.
I'm gonna give you
$250,000,
but for 28%.
28%.
Okay.
Is there any way you'd
be willing to do 25%?
Um...
Tell me three things
about you...
Oh, Lord...
...that make you fantastic
as a partner.
Okay, I work nonstop.
I work every single day.
Two, when I put my mind to
something, I get it done.
Three, I feel like
I'm kind of funny,
so I might make you
laugh a little bit.
‐There you go.
‐There's a bonus.
‐Aww!
‐Bravo!
Maybe?
Do you know the word "no"?
Doesn't exist.
Deal!
Yes! Great!
All right!
We'll take it.
‐Congrats, guys.
‐Awesome.
All right.
I like it!
I'd give you a hug,
but I am all hairy, so..
Eww!
I'm clean.
Tyson's got all the hugs.
Thank you so much.
Tyson will hug twice.
‐I can't wait to work with you.
‐It's awesome.
Thank you very much.
We appreciate the offer.
‐Congrats, guys.
‐Thank you. Congrats.
All right, we got Lori.
That's who we wanted.
Lori can bring
a lot to the table.
Her on QVC selling the product
will be great.
She loved it, and she's gonna
sell a ton of them. We know it.
Good job, Harley.
I think you won Lori over.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is a better way to carry
your most precious cargo.
♪♪
Hey, Sharks.
My name is Nathan Day,
and I'm from Gilbert, Arizona.
My company is LugBug,
the most convenient way
to carry a child seat.
I'm seeking $300,000 in exchange
for 10% of my company.
I'm gonna need some help
to demo this.
Robert, you just had twins.
Why don't you come up here
and give me a hand.
I am an expert.
Come on, new dad.
Go get 'em.
Robert, pick up the dumbbell
in one hand for me.
[ Grunting ]
[ Laughter ]
All right.
Yeah.
Very strong.
Love it.
Now, hang it down
by your side
how'd you normally
carry the dumbbell.
Now, do you see how the weight
hangs naturally at his side,
with his palm facing in?
I want you to pick up
the car seat in your other hand.
Look how awkward
that is.
It's not a natural way
to carry weight,
nor is it good for your arm
or your shoulder.
In fact,
nearly half of all parents
experience shoulder,
back, and neck pain
due to lugging around
a baby carrier.
So I did something
about it.
I created LugBug,
the most convenient way
to carry a child seat.
Just clip LugBug
on your handle here.
And if you need to adjust it,
you simply press down, rotate,
and let it click into place.
Oh, wow.
But, you know, Robert,
to get the true feel of this,
I thought we might need
a little bit more help.
So come on out, guys!
‐Aww!
‐Ohh!
[ Laughter ]
Yes! [ Laughs ]
Ohhhh!
They're so teeny!
Aww!
O'Leary: Robert,
you're scaring that child.
‐Oh, my God.
‐Aww!
Guys, I'd like
to introduce you.
You guys all know Kymmy,
of course.
I'd like to introduce you
to Hudson.
[ Deep voice ]
Hi, Mark. Hi, Barbara.
‐What's up, Hudson?
‐Hey, Hudson.
[ Normal voice ] And this
beautiful child is Haven!
[ Coos ]
Oh. Shh.
Day:
So, let's try it out.
Okay.
Yeah.
It is easier.
'Cause you don't know if you
want to carry it like that or...
Correct.
...this way.
It's definitely better
on the wrists.
Does it add weight?
It does add weight.
It's currently 12.6 ounces.
Okay.
Just a little bit.
You don't really notice that.
Let me pass those out.
Herjavec: Yeah.
Here you go.
Any one?
Yep.
You can take the packaging, too,
if you like.
You're here!
Can I see one of
those boxes, as well?
Yeah.
Thank you very much.
‐You're welcome.
Feels well‐built.
Oh, wow. Okay.
Day: Well, thank you so much
for joining us.
‐Yeah, thank you very much.
‐I appreciate it.
I'll take the babies away.
‐Bye!
Herjavec: Bye, Hudson!
Bye, Haven!
Day: Thank you.
Herjavec: All right,
what does it cost you, Nathan?
Did you ever tell us?
The product retails
for $39.99.
First thing I did was file for
a patentability letter.
It was just to see,
is this product out there?
Has it been done before?
‐Did you get it?
I have four issued
in the U. S.
Greiner: Wow.
I have six pending.
‐Four patents?
‐Four patents.
‐Utility or design?
Utility.
I have six pending worldwide.
Okay, this is great,
but do you have any sales?
I do have sales. I have
a cumulative $283,000 in sales.
I launched ‐‐
I hate that.
Don't ever tell me
cumulative.
‐For how many years?
‐How long?
That's 2016, '17, and '18.
So, what were sales
last year?
$198,000 ‐‐ all online.
And what does it cost you
to make a unit?
The handle itself,
manufactured overseas, is $4.31.
With packaging, duties,
and landed,
I'm at $5.92.
Get me excited about
the retailers you've talked to
that want to bring it in
and test it.
Do you have a Target
or Walmart
that wants to actually
put it in the store?
No.
Why not?
Target and Walmart would like
to try it out online.
How much
have you invested?
Okay, so, over the years,
with the patents,
I've put in $750,000.
‐Whoa!
‐What?!
‐Unbelievable.
Where did you get
the $750,000, Nathan?
Um, it's personal ‐‐
uh, personal capital.
Yes, it is personal,
isn't it?
Greiner: Yeah, what did
all that money go into?
So, tooling, manufacturing,
patents.
Cuban: Look, Nathan,
I think it's a good idea,
but your challenge is,
you haven't quite figured out
the way to market it
in a way that people understand.
It kind of says
what it is,
but it really has to
be demonstrated.
I don't know that you have
an immediate answer for that.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
Okay, Robert, are you
buying two of these?
No.
I'll tell you why
I'm not buying the product,
and I'll demonstrate something
for you, Nathan.
I went to the doctor with
the twins the first time...
Okay.
...and I was swinging the babies
around and doing it all badly.
And the doctor
looked at me and said,
"You haven't done this
for a while, have you?"
He goes, "Let me show you
an easier way to do it.
Just do that. Just carry it
around like this."
Oh, that's better.
You could do this
a lot longer
than you can do this.
Right,
but you could do that
a lot longer than
you could do the twist.
I'll tell you,
you're a great salesman,
but let me tell you what is
of great concern to me.
It's your judgment.
The idea that
you could spend $750,000
developing this product
is mind‐boggling to me.
You went and got all these
patents before you had sales.
What good are the patents
if you don't have the sales?
As much as I like you,
I'm out.
Look, does anybody
really want this product?
The patents intrigue me.
The revenues don't.
I'm out.
Thank you.
Nathan, first of all,
I loved your super‐hot model
and the two babies.
‐[ Laughs ]
Love that.
I admire how
you got to market.
I completely disagree
with Kevin.
If you can get $200,000
in sales in two years
on a $30 product,
that's a lot of volume units,
so I applaud you for that.
‐Thank you.
‐But still, you won't buy it?
Well, I accept
people are buying it,
but I'm carrying around
baby seats all the time.
I don't carry them
long enough
where I would think
I would need this.
If I'm not gonna
buy the product,
I can't buy the company.
I'm out.
Now, it's all you, Lori.
What are you gonna do?
O'Leary: Don't give him the
kumbaya, "You keep going" thing.
I'm not giving him
the kumbaya.
Tell him the truth.
He needs the truth.
No, no, listen.
It's a smart concept.
Your only play
is to take this
to a baby seat carrier
and license it.
Help me get there.
I don't really think
that you need
my help to do that.
I'm out.
‐Good luck to you.
‐Nathan, thank you.
‐Good luck.
Day: I believe in LugBug,
and I'm gonna continue
believing in LugBug.
Robert said
he wasn't gonna buy it,
but when his kids
are 6 months old,
he's gonna be coming back.
Kevin O'Leary helped us
grow Lovepop 100x
in the last three years.
Together, we've created
7 million magical moments.
All: Thank you, "Shark Tank"!
[ Cheering ]
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is
a solution to a problem
some well‐endowed women face.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name's Erin Robertson.
I'm from Los Angeles,
California,
and I'm seeking $200,000
for 10% equity in my company.
I'm in the business
of keeping boobs high and dry.
[ Laughter ]
That's right ‐‐ boob sweat.
I know it doesn't sound
very attractive,
and trust me, it does not
feel very attractive, either,
but it is something that's
very real for so many women.
One hot summer day, I was
getting ready to go on a date,
and I could not stop sweating.
Fresh out of the shower,
I grabbed my T‐shirt
and I put it on and I tucked it
underneath my girls,
but that just made me
even hotter.
The struggle is real.
So I came up with
a solution of my own ‐‐
the Ta‐Ta Towel.
That's right ‐‐
it's a towel for yo' ta‐tas.
‐Whoa!
‐Wow!
‐Oh, my goodness!
‐Uh...
Daymond's gonna be so upset
he's not here.
The Ta‐Ta Towel
is terry cloth on one side
and a super‐soft liner on the
other, making it reversible.
It's like your girls
are on vacation,
lounging in hammocks somewhere.
And who doesn't love
a good vacation?
So, Sharks, who wants to join me
in the boobie business
and get your hands
on my Ta‐Ta Towels?
[ Laughs ]
So, they walk around
outside like that?
I came up with it just for
getting out of the shower,
and I just figured
for around the house.
However, I have had some
amazing customers and women
who buy these, and they are
wearing them everywhere.
So, you cinch it tighter
from the neck?
Yes.
And also tighten it
underneath?
Absolutely. And you can wiggle,
move, dance around,
and your girls will stay ‐‐
‐Can you bend forward?
‐Absolutely.
How endowed do the girls
have to be?
The smallest size
is a small ‐‐ or a big C.
The biggest size
it goes up to is an H.
Wow.
‐Let me pass these out first.
‐All right.
This is for you.
Thank you.
I could try this
on Kevin's head, though.
It's about the same.
‐Kevin, this is for you.
We thought you might want
to feel how it really feels.
There you go.
[ Laughter ]
I really don't need
one of these at all.
But you know what ‐‐
they make great gifts.
I could see this working.
Oh, there you ‐‐ Pfft.
Yeah, see? There you go.
It looks really good on you.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Oh, my God.
Did you put a patent
on these little puppies?
Yes, sir. I have a patent
and a trademark
registered here
and in China.
Is it a design patent
or utility?
It is a design patent
for the original,
which you have,
and then the second towel
that you have
is my second patent pending,
for maternity.
Herjavec:
What does it sell for?
The originals sell for $45, and
the maternities sell for $55.
And what does it cost you
to make?
$24.
‐Oh, that's high.
‐How many have you sold?
12 months,
I've sold $1.1 million.
‐Whoa!
‐Whoa.
‐Wow.
‐You're kidding!
‐It costs you $24 ‐‐
‐Congratulations!
Thank you for saying that.
So, you're selling them
all online, right?
I sell them only exclusively
from my website.
Cuban: You've got to be
just crushing it,
rolling in the dough
right now.
It's been life‐changing.
Right before this happened,
I'd been a personal assistant
for 13 years.
Hated my life.
It was a really difficult job.
So I quit,
and I was making all of these
in my living room.
I YouTubed how to sew.
I couldn't even thread
the needle or, like,
get it in there,
and I started
making them myself.
‐You're amazing.
‐But then ‐‐
‐Wow!
‐Thank you.
When I first came up with this,
I started handing them out.
And then, out of nowhere,
I don't know who got their hands
on these towels,
but all of a sudden, whenever
I get a sale on my phone,
something would just
drop down, right?
Like, ding, sale.
Ding, sale.
And all of a sudden, I just see
ding, ding, ding, ding, ding,
ding, ding, ding, ding, and
I thought my phone was broken.
Like Las Vegas.
So, my neighbor runs out
and she's like,
"Have you been online?
You are everywhere!"
Oh, so it just ‐‐
it went viral on its own?
On its own.
Do you manufacture
here still?
I am proud to say
I manufacture in Los Angeles.
They are handmade by women,
for women,
in an eco‐friendly
manufacturer.
Good for you.
O'Leary: Do you think
you could increase the price
because it's domestically
made by hand?
Yeah, 'cause your margins
are low, honestly.
What set me back
in the beginning
is I went viral, right,
and I did not know
what I was doing.
Everyone took advantage of that
and jumped on
and tried to rip me off
and steal.
So I had to take a break.
Did you enforce
your patents?
So, we enforced my patent.
What are you gonna sell
this year?
We're on track
to sell $2 million.
And what are your sales
year‐to‐date?
$188,000.
For the year?
Wait, wait, wait.
Okay.
You're gonna go from $180,000
in the first six months
to $2 million for
the rest of the year?
Absolutely. We have so many
people from all over the world.
Like I said,
I had to close down ‐‐
How are you
gonna do that?
I'm still trying to
get my head around
going from $180,000, six months,
to $2 million.
Well, the reason is
is that ‐‐
First of all,
the towels really work.
O'Leary:
But that's not the problem.
We all assume it works.
You have to make it to get
the $2 million in sales,
and you've only got
six months.
Yeah, oh, I have
inventory on hand.
‐How much?
I have 10,000 units on hand.
Do you have $2 million
worth of inventory right now?
Oh, no, no,
not $2 million.
Here's the problem.
A lot of things aren't
adding up right now.
You had this viral moment.
That propelled sales
in a short period of time
to $1 million.
Yes.
You come into this year,
and you don't have
the viral moment
and you have
all the aggravation
of shutting down
all the knock‐offs.
But $250,000 in inventory
equals a half a million dollars
in sales.
Uh‐huh.
So you got to be able
to turn your inventory
four times, basically ‐‐
Well, isn't QVC great?
I mean, I'm ready for 'em.
I've got the product.
Have you talked to them?
No.
Wait, I don't think
there's any way in the world
that you're getting
to $2 million in sales
unless you have another one
of those viral moments.
Well, that's why I'm here,
honestly, is,
I'm not afraid to say that,
like, I have this inventory.
I don't know
what to do with it.
They are selling.
Sales are consistent.
But it's not just viral ‐‐
it's also going global.
Like I said ‐‐
‐Forget about global.
You've got to show it working
in the U. S. market.
You're kind of
making my case, right,
because to think that
the world is your oyster
and if you only sell
the entire world,
then you're gonna get
$2 million,
it doesn't really
work that way.
You're just a little bit
too scattered for me.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
Okay. Well, thank you.
Erin, the words
"I have all this inventory,
and I don't know
what to do with it"
is pretty scary
to an investor.
Never good. Yeah.
I shouldn't have said, "I don't
know what to do with it."
Well, I know,
but you did say it.
And it doesn't mean that
you have to be punished for it.
What it means, though,
is there's no strategic plan.
It's not selling, Erin.
However, when I went viral,
that inventory I'm sitting on
would be completely gone.
But you can't
predict viral.
You're right,
so I prepared for it now,
so now
I have the inventory.
You keep saying,
"I went viral."
You're answering future problems
with past solutions.
I am here because this is
how far I've gotten.
Your strategy is hope.
And hope is great,
but in business,
hope is not really
a great strategy.
I'm out.
Okay.
Thank you. Thank you.
Erin, you're a product person
with a great idea.
But I'm looking for the person
that is gonna show me
exactly how I'm getting
to $2 million in sales.
I really struggle with it
because I like it.
And, you know, I didn't know
about large...sweat issues.
[ Laughs ]
And now I do.
And that's great,
and, you know,
I learned something today,
but I can‐‐
What's it worth today,
Kevin?
It's not even worth
$200,000.
You haven't proven out
what you can do here.
It's worth $250,000.
She'll sell her inventory.
Erin, I'm really sorry.
It's a great product,
but I'm out.
Okay.
Erin, the part
that concerns me
is no one wants
to buy into a business
when the sales are sliding,
versus going up.
Sorry to say ‐‐ I'm out.
Okay.
Well,
there's one Shark left.
O'Leary: What are you
gonna do, Lori?
Well, Erin, I will tell you
what my thought is.
You had me at "hello."
Aww.
I get it.
I get this product.
Great.
But my offer
is commensurate
to the work that
we're gonna have to do.
Okay.
Okay?
So I want to be
a 50‐50 partner.
[ Gasps ]
Ruh‐roh!
Narrator:
Four Sharks are out.
Lori is interested
in Ta‐Ta Towel,
a towel to combat
underboob sweat,
but she wants
half the business.
So I want to be
a 50‐50 partner.
[ Gasps ]
Ta, ta, ta, ta!
I will make you a millionaire,
'cause that's what I do.
Um, I mean, I would just love
to jump at that,
because it's amazing and I
really do want to work with you.
Giving up 50% of my company
is just something
that I really can't do
at this moment.
Uh, would you take...
...like, 15%?
‐Ohhhh!
‐Oh, my God!
20%?
Oh, my God!
I know!
Remember something.
Okay.
Your business has slowed
dramatically.
Mm‐hmm.
You need an army
to help you.
I've got an army.
Is there an scenario
where you'd give her 50%?
[ Inhales, exhales slowly ]
You increase the money, perhaps?
Is there any scenario?
Um, 50%, no,
because when I was broke
and couldn't pay bills,
I took an investor,
and I gave them 10%.
So I own 90%.
Listen, I'm gonna ‐‐
Best offer...
$200,000, 40%.
And my army.
Listen, you're gonna make
so much money,
you're not gonna mind.
Uh, would you do...30%?
Ugh.
50% of a watermelon
is a whole lot better
than 90% of a grape.
Yay, I've got watermelons
in here, by the way.
[ Laughs ]
Erin, you got to make
a decision.
This way, you're not gonna be sorry.
You got to make a decision.
I won't be sorry.
Would you be able to go up
in the money, then,
if I give you that much?
Cuban: Oy!
Give her a chance.
That's her option.
Let her speak.
So, your final offer
is...?
$200,000, 40%.
But you will blow this up.
Erin, it's not gonna make
a difference 10% either way.
Make a decision.
But also, Erin, you have
to be happy with it.
You're absolutely right.
Look, I am so happy
for this offer.
I need the help. Like you said,
I've made a lot of mistakes ‐‐
So,
what are you gonna do?
♪♪
I'm gonna ‐‐
I'm gonna take her offer.
‐Yes!
‐Yay!
‐All right.
‐Thank you, guys.
Yippie aye oh ki‐yay!
I really appreciate it!
I'm so happy!
Cuban: 40%.
What kind of melons
are those?
They're midsize,
but they're very comfortable.
My dad told me not to cry.
Greiner: That's okay.
You can cry.
Group hug! Group hug!
Herjavec: Ohh!
I'm gonna cry, too.
Congratulations, Erin.
Congratulations.
Oooh! [ Laughs ]
I'm just feeling
really grateful.
This has been
a really hard road,
and I really believe
in this product,
and I know it works
so, so well.
And to be able to get a deal
with a Shark that I wanted,
it's perfect.
♪♪
Narrator: In Season 7,
Steve and Angela Watts
landed a deal with Mark Cuban
and Ashton Kutcher
for their miniature surfboards,
Slyde Handboards.
Let's see what
they're up to now.
We've grown from a niche market
to a worldwide water sport.
Today is Slyde Fest,
the second annual charity
handboard competition.
We've got riders in
from all over the world.
Oh, nice!
Angela:
When we went on "Shark Tank,"
Steve and I were engaged.
But we used the money my mom
had saved for our wedding
to grow the business.
Now we're able
to pay her back,
get married,
and have our new baby girl.
The year before "Shark Tank,"
we did $159,000 in sales.
It's been two years,
and we've done
over $1.3 million in sales.
‐Ash.
‐Hey!
‐What up?
‐How's it going?
Kutcher: The thing I liked
about Slyde,
they're actually
giving people a way that,
if they don't surf,
if they don't boogie board,
that they can get in the water
and do something fun,
and I think that that's amazing.
This grom handboard
is the key for us.
The board, pretty much
anybody can afford.
This is the game changer,
guys.
And we're really excited
to bring this
to Dick's Sporting Goods
this summer.
Cuban:
Through our team, we have a
great relationship with Dick's,
so we introduced them,
and they loved the product.
We were able to get them
distribution nationwide,
and that accessibility
is critical
for creating
what's effectively a new sport.
This deal is gonna go
incredibly well.
The only question is,
who's next?
Steve: I personally can't
believe how far it's come.
I get up every morning
and do what I love to do.
I get to work
with my beautiful wife.
It's an incredible
life to live ‐‐
basically, all thanks
to "Shark Tank."
♪♪
Narrator: Next in the Tank
is a more sophisticated version
of a traditional snack.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Keisha Jeremie,
and my company
is Sanaía Applesauce.
I'm asking for $150,000
for 15% in my company.
Now, Sharks,
have you ever noticed that
the entire applesauce industry
has been completely ignoring us?
They're focused on 8‐year‐olds
and they're focused
on 80‐year‐olds,
and they're leaving
a ton of money on the table.
'Cause think about it ‐‐
if you're an adult
and you're looking for
applesauce on shelves,
the options are really slim.
Basically, they've been
asking us to settle
for baby food
all these years ‐‐
baby food flavors,
baby food consistency,
and now pouches.
Sharks, I am a grown woman.
I am not doing pouches.
And so I've finally decided to
take matters into my own hands.
Introducing Sanaía.
I've taken organic green apples
and curated six
island‐inspired flavors.
I've also done something else
that no one else
has thought of ‐‐
in every jar,
you'll find baked apple wedges.
Oh.
Today, you're meeting
the woman
who's about to take the entire
applesauce category by storm.
When the yogurt industry finally
started listening to adults
and gave them a snack
that they actually deserve,
that $8 billion category
turned into $125 billion.
So what I'm about to do
is take these green apples
and turn them into billions
of green dollars.
Who's coming with me?
So, I also have
some samples for you.
Hopefully, I've tempted you.
‐Thank you. Yeah.
I love applesauce.
Thank you.
So, these are four
of our six flavors.
Thank you.
Thanks, Keisha.
Appreciate it.
♪♪
‐The guava's good.
‐Guava, yep.
The plain apple's
delicious.
‐The unsweetened version?
‐Oh, yeah, this one's good.
It doesn't taste
processed.
Right.
And are you
in the market today,
or is this brand‐new?
So, this is ‐‐
We just launched in July.
We did a test market for
six months, direct‐to‐consumer.
And what are
your sales today?
So, we achieved $40,000 of sales
in that six‐month test pilot.
Are people buying it because
they like the flavor
or do you see it
as a health food?
Well, they're buying it
because a lot of people
are looking for
plant‐based, right?
They're looking
to move away from dairy.
And it's vegan.
Vegans actually bake with
applesauce instead of eggs.
Keisha, how do you sell it,
and what is the cost?
The glass jar is gonna be
our product on Amazon Prime.
It's going to be sold
as a four‐pack of flavors.
The glass jar is $1.03
and $3.99 per jar to retail.
Right, so $3.99 times four,
so, effectively, $16 at retail.
That's right.
And your cost is $4.12.
Is that not expensive
for applesauce?
So, again, you know, we're not
comparing ourselves to Mott's.
As I mentioned
in the opening,
this is essentially what
Chobani did with yogurt, right?
They took a category
that was pretty sleepy
and they elevated
the flavors,
they elevated the positioning,
they elevated the packaging.
We just spent
the last 48 hours
at the IDDBA conference ‐‐
or trade show ‐‐
and we came back
with close to $35 million
in projected revenue,
based on interest.
Oh, please.
I'm not buying it, Keisha.
‐I'll tell you ‐‐
‐Wait, wait.
‐Yeah, tell us how.
‐Explain who said what.
‐Hang on a second.
‐I'll tell you. I'll tell you.
Corcoran: Give her a chance.
Give her a chance.
I'll tell you.
So, Starbucks, Whole Foods,
Sam's Club, BJ's, Kroger's,
literally buyers sending
other buyers to us.
They were referring to us
at the show ‐‐
O'Leary: They're not
giving you orders, right?
Well, it's not
an order‐taking conference.
But before the trade show,
we'd already had a commitment
with Whole Foods.
A test with Whole Foods?
Whole Foods in Harlem.
So one store?
One store.
What I heard
was "$35 million."
Yep.
So how did you get there?
Why do you say that?
So, if we look at ‐‐
'Cause everything was
going great till I heard that.
So, what happened,
basically,
is we had a number of buyers
come to us ‐‐
Did you get a firm order
from anybody?
We have not received
firm orders from them.
But they ‐‐ what we received is
basically confirmed interest.
They came by,
they basically said,
"No one else is doing this.
This immediately belongs
in our refrigerated section."
Actually, I want to show you
the pictures of what they ‐‐
Oh.
They're putting it
into a yogurt cup,
not a glass jar?
That's different.
Could we see that?
Sure.
‐Oh, so this is a new product.
‐Oh.
So, this is the product that
we've been talking to grocers ‐‐
‐That's a better idea.
Still the same flavors.
Keisha,
what's your background?
I'm currently global head of HR
for one of
the largest publishing companies
in the country.
‐Well, that's related.
‐Which one?
News Corp.
News Corporation.
Oh, very impressive.
So, I've been there
for six years.
And you pull this off
on the side?
And I've been doing it ‐‐
But I also, uh ‐‐
I've been building
high‐performance teams
for 20 years,
and so I immediately knew
that I needed to build a team
to do this.
So, you're not gonna go
full time into this?
Well, at this moment,
it doesn't make sense
for me to be full‐time,
but I have a COO
who literally is minutes away
from our production plant,
and this is his full‐time job.
So, did you raise
a lot of money, Keisha?
It sounds expensive.
I have been self‐funding it
so far.
$250,000 is what I've spent
so far on it.
Wow.
It seems to me
like you got very far
for $250,000.
Cuban: Yeah.
This product
versus this product ‐‐
what's your plan
for this?
The glass jars will be
on Amazon Prime in two weeks.
‐That's horrible.
‐Oh, you're launching that?
The glass jars in two weeks
on Amazon.
Why are you ‐‐ the shipping cost
is gonna be enormous.
The weight of the glass is
the same as the liquid inside.
Well, we're able to make close
to 50% margins on the glass,
margins of 46%.
What will the cost of
this be, if this one ‐‐
This is 63 cents to make.
‐Oh.
‐63 cents to make.
But to sell?
To sell
will be, um, $1...
$1.02 wholesale,
and then we're thinking $1.79.
This is the most expensive
applesauce ever sold in America.
I guess what I would
respond to in that is,
the person who buys Mott's today
is not really our consumer.
Cuban: So, here's
the problem I'm having.
I see where you're going.
Right?
Right.
Create a new category.
This is gonna be hard,
if not impossible, to sell
because you're not
an established brand.
Now, this, on the other hand,
if it's a grab‐and‐go,
why are you complicating it
with this?
Well, so, we ‐‐
This is where we started.
Greiner: For me,
it's really super basic.
It's, how popular is
applesauce for adults?
I'm not really
an applesauce fan.
You know, after 10 seasons
sitting here,
going out on a person's dream
is never easy...
Mm‐hmm.
...and it pains me
to sit here and say,
but I'm out.
That's fine.
I respect that.
Herjavec: Keisha,
I have to tell you,
your presentation
was very impressive
until we got
to the trade show.
Okay.
When you confuse interest
with actual orders,
it leaves me
with doubt.
It's just not for me.
Okay.
I'm out.
I respect that.
Thank you.
I happen to think both
of your products are great ‐‐
for a lot of reasons.
I don't think your price
is out of line.
Your retail is 2 bucks.
That's about right, with
everything else on the shelf.
I thought
the flavor was phenomenal,
and the texture,
creamy and delicious ‐‐
Are you gonna
make her an offer?
Wait a minute.
The major point is,
you're definitely a dreamer,
but you can't justify
the dream,
and that's very disturbing.
I mean, the numbers
you throw out,
I can't believe each time
you give an explanation
how you're gonna
get there.
Okay.
But there are businesses where
it's worth taking a flyer on.
Yep.
You could be
the next big thing.
But the kind of offer
I'd have to make you,
I'm afraid I'd insult you.
Would any offer insult you
at this point?
I don't think any offer
would insult me.
I'm curious to see what you
think the valuation is.
I would give you the $150,000,
but I would have to get...
...at least 75%.
♪♪
Narrator: Two Sharks are out.
Barbara is interested
in Keisha's
gourmet applesauce, Sanaía,
but she wants a huge chunk
of her company.
I would give you
the $150,000,
but I would have to get
at least 75%.
By the way,
did that insult you?
Didn't insult me.
It was just interesting.
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Herjavec: Well said.
Would you like
to accept my offer?
No, that's not an offer
that we can take. Thank you.
I'm out.
We've been through this.
We've all looked
at food products.
I'm not saying you're wrong,
but I'm saying it's risky.
It really is risky.
And you're not full‐time,
which, I got to tell you,
really bothers me.
If you really believe this,
you'd quit your job
and you'd be telling me that
you don't sleep on weekends.
I don't sleep on weekends.
[ Laughter ]
But I'm also
the breadwinner,
and it's not an option
for everyone.
No, I get it,
but, you know, it's ‐‐
That's not an option for everyone, yeah.
Not everybody can do that.
But there's a difference.
I can invest
in an entrepreneur that does.
I'm out.
How much cash do you have
in the bank?
So, I have set aside, uh,
close to $500,000
for the business,
'cause I'm self‐funding it
right now.
So you've put in
$250,000 already,
and you have another $250,000
of your savings...
Correct.
Look, you have a presence
about you.
You know this.
You have a power about you.
What I haven't been convinced of
is that you're an entrepreneur.
I get you're a breadwinner.
You have those responsibilities.
That's always a push/pull
that people have.
But at the same time,
we all were broke.
I'm not convinced.
Here's what I can tell you.
I didn't have to
start the business.
If I did not see
the market opportunity,
I would not put
my life savings into it.
I do work
around the clock.
It is definitely not
a part‐time gig
in the way
that you've described it.
Well, you do work
somewhere else.
I do work somewhere else,
but "part‐time" sounds like
you're checking in
and checking out.
Yes, it does.
Well, I think it is.
But I also think that because
it couldn't be my full‐time job
right out of the gate,
I put a team in place.
That's great.
You're an owner.
From a risk profile,
why aren't you throwing
everything into this?
I cannot afford to.
Look, I think
that's so unfair.
Cry me a river. You think the world
is fair? The luxury of
leaving her job and doing it ‐‐
She's not working
full time.
I started my first company,
I wanted to be all‐in.
You know what?
I had a mortgage.
I had a child at home.
I didn't have that choice.
Kumbaya!
So I had to work
24 hours a day.
She's not asking
for kumbaya.
Are you kidding?
She's just saying she has
a family to support.
Entrepreneurs come in here
every day,
they're full‐time, 110%.
Keisha, why are you
tearing up? Tell me.
Is there like...
"De‐de‐de‐de‐de"?
Why are you tearing up?
Um...
♪♪
There's ‐‐ there are...
I take care of
so many people financially.
Um...
[ Sobs ]
This is the first thing
I've ever done for myself.
♪♪
And I would never squander
the commitments that I have
to family members
if I didn't
believe in it.
Who is it
that relies on you?
Uh, my mom, my dad,
my siblings.
Um,
I'm the person who...
made it.
So, really, you're absolutely
right to keep your job...
Yeah.
...and take care of the people
that you're taking care of
and fulfill your dream
on the side.
Cuban: You're impressive.
And even though I think
you're missing a few things,
[ Chuckles ] I think
that my team can provide it.
so I'll make you
an offer.
Thank you. Thank you.
I'll give you the 150K,
but I want 25%.
I'm comfortable doing that.
‐Whoa!
‐Yay!
[ Applause ]
Corcoran:
He's my hero.
‐Thank you.
I appreciate it.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
I'm very excited.
We'll do this.
Congrats, Keisha!
‐Congrats, Keisha.
‐That felt so good!
Keisha, I'm gonna
make you focus on this.
‐Yes, I got it.
‐...over the glass, okay?
I heard that loud and clear.
Okay, we'll make it work.
♪♪
I literally am giving every
single thing to this business.
I believe in it
so wholeheartedly.
And I'm just so happy
that I got a deal.
I got a deal!
[ Laughs ]
I'm so excited!
I wanted to know
if she was all‐in,
and I wanted to know
if it mattered to her,
you know, that she had ‐‐
Oh, it mattered to her.
She went from being, you know,
executive‐like to ‐‐
The entrepreneur in her
came out.
♪♪